i started the race to run for congress
and part of that reason was because
maxine waters trying to get help with my
va benefits
um i was sleeping outside the lighthouse
at rancho's palace verdes
and i was going to her office every
other day trying to get help i filled
all job applications internships i even
bought her flowers
and i was met with silence and that
really made me upset because majority of
the people who live on the streets are
homeless veterans and then
60 of them are black and so you have
this lady who says well i'm pro-black
this pro-black that i fight for black
people all of this stuff and here i am a
young black man
and you're not fighting for me we have
44 000 homeless people on the street 60
of them are black veterans you're not
fighting for those people so which
which black people are you fighting for
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report we're doing a mini interview
today with joe collins joe is a u.s
navy veteran and a republican running
for congress in los angeles 43rd
district
looking to unseat maxine waters who's
been in congress for a cool
44 years i caught winda joe after his
viral
campaign ad that i'm sure many of you
have seen so we're going to show you
just a bite of that and then
get right to the interview with joe here
we go
[Music]
i'm joe collins i'm running for congress
against maxine waters
do you know where i am right now maxine
waters is
six million dollar mansion do you know
where i'm not right now
maxine waters district yup that's right
maxine does not live in her district
but i do i was born right here in south
l.a
in a place maxine refuses to live maxine
waters does not drink our water
she does not breathe our air and while
she sits here in her mansion
our district is in ruins let me show you
this is south la i was born here i grew
up on 104th normandy
maxine waters has been in office of 44
years has anything got better around
here
i can tell you firsthand that it hasn't
i survived a drive-by shooting
in this house when i was a child gangs
drugs
violence that was my upbringing and
where was maxine waters
nowhere to be found joe how's it going
today
good how are you i'm doing well i'm
doing well so look you put that
that ad up and much like the kim klasik
ad it caught fire
uh are are new people heading your way
do you feel like you have some momentum
right now
oh yeah um you know uh success leaves
clues and we saw what kim did and we
absolutely
you know you know did one of our own and
people have been coming
our way for a very long time be getting
a lot of support but i think one of the
biggest things was we had to actually
shine a light on how maxine is compared
to how we live in the district and
and we absolutely nailed it with that
yeah all right so before we get to a
little
a little of your history which is pretty
amazing and you've done some great stuff
let's talk about maxine waters because
in the ad you talk about the fact that
she lives
in a six million dollar mansion that is
not
in that district if i'm not mistaken
she's in hancock park which is a pretty
swanky
swanky area of l.a obviously not
south central but that she's also been
in business and by business i mean
government
for 44 years how did she get a 6
million dollar mansion which i don't
begrudge someone earning money
honestly but in 44 years of public
service you usually don't think of
someone getting a six million dollar
mansion
yeah you know she has a ton of mansions
and um from doing research i've seen a
lot of backhanded things that she's been
doing you know pocket padding and all
that other type of stuff
and uh we have to say you know it has to
be corruption she's been labeled the
most corrupt politician five times by
the citizens for ethics committee
she has a she has her own page and the
judicial watch
uh called career corruption and uh it
features maxine waters and everything
she's been doing she's gotten
a lot of backhanded deals she's even
she's even ripped off politicians
um here in california she put they pay
her 45 000
uh dollars for an endorsement and
another you know ten fifteen twenty
thousand dollars to get on the slate
mailer scheme that yeah i was going so
i mean when it comes to the corruption
of maxine waters it knows no limit
yeah so all right i don't want to get
too lost on maxine because i think your
your feelings about her
are clear and i have a feeling most of
my audience probably agrees with you but
but let's talk about you
because i don't think most people think
that wait
a black republican from south central
could that could that possibly exist
now we know a lot of stereotypes are
being broken these days
but can you tell me a little bit about
your history
so yeah i'm from south central los
angeles i was born and raised there
and uh we ended up having to move to
texas um after my house was shot up at a
drive-by
so i was already in high school so i
ended up finishing high school in texas
i graduated in 2003 joined the navy in
2004 that's where i became a republican
and the reason why is because in the
history of um
of black people we see that the first
black man to get involved in politics
we're republicans
and that's what the republican party
stood for freedom
anti-slavery fight for your rights and
and that's what resonated with me
so what possessed you to possibly go
into politics
you come back after the navy and what
what possessed you to say all right i'm
going to throw my hat in the ring
i actually got out the military to get
involved in politics i'll take you
i got an administrative separation
general under honorable conditions so i
can pursue a career in politics and it
was because uh through the 2016 election
the voice of the younger people were not
being heard and everybody called us lazy
millennials they called us lazy they
said we were worthless we couldn't do
anything and mind you
in a navy in an entire military in
itself it's about four million
millennials that wake up every day at
four o'clock in the morning we do more
between four and eight than most people
do
all day and so whenever we would bring
our issues to the table they'll say wait
or it's not your turn yeah we're gonna
take care of it for you but our voice
was never heard
so i wanted our voice to be heard so i
got out the military hopped into
politics i actually started off as a
presidential candidate
and um you know after i learned a lot
because
you know you can't get involved in
politics in the military so i learned a
lot as a presidential candidate then i
started
the race to run for congress and part of
that reason was because maxine waters
trying to get help with my va benefits
um i was sleeping outside the lighthouse
of ranchers palace verdes and i was
going to her office every other day
trying to get help i filled out job
applications internships i even brought
her flowers and i was met with silence
and that really made me upset because
majority of the people who live on the
streets are homeless veterans and then
60 of them are black and so you have
this lady who says well i'm pro-black
this pro-black that i fight for black
people all of this stuff and here i am a
young black man
and you're not fighting for me we have
44 000 homeless people on the street 60
of them are black veterans you're not
fighting for those people so which
which black people are you fighting for
you know and so she has to she got her
she got to go
yeah so why is it you know i'm in la as
well
and why is it do you think that people
in la
and really california as a whole but i
think la and san francisco specifically
seem unable to connect the dots between
always voting in democrats and things
always getting worse
they seem to not be able to realize oh
we keep doing the same thing
and things keep going the wrong
direction maybe we gotta vote in some
other people
have you figured out why that is i think
it's because
when it when it comes to politics and
this is something that i've noticed um
you know a lot of candidates don't run
to win they want to be famous they want
to be social media influencers so they
don't put in the necessary work that it
takes to
um to win a campaign to raise money to
get their message out
and so that's what we've been seeing for
a very long time people want change but
if they don't know you exist they can't
vote for you
yeah so so what are the things that you
want to do i mean we all know the
homeless situation in la is
is just it almost seems like every week
it gets worse
what are some of like the heart give me
like three four of just the the linchpin
things that you want to accomplish and
how you're going to do it
okay well i have my five-point plan and
the reason why i came over
i'll go with all five let's do all three
okay all right so i want to
rebuild the infrastructure to support
the expansion of
small businesses as well as housing i
want to overhaul
education and start rebuilding our high
schools in the 43rd district i want to
bring quality jobs back
improve the relationship between the law
enforcement and the community and also
want to bring financial literacy back
and these are just basics basic things
that you need in order to
have a productive positive society so we
have to get back to the basics
and you know you ask how am i do it it's
easy you just go to work and you do your
job and i know that on a private
capacity what we've been able to do um
with the campaign what i've been able to
do in the community
as far as bringing jobs and taking care
of our community because 19 is
absolutely possible and
it's easy you just have to want to do it
yeah let's talk about the the policing
situation because obviously everyone's
talking about that all the time uh
what do you make about the the relations
between the police and
i hate phrases like the black community
but
you know with at least the constituents
in your district right now
you know it's kind of tough because
everybody over emphasizes
the um the issues of police brutality
and inner cities and they ignore
uh everything else that we have going on
in our communities and
a lot of times um you know when you hear
a black person was shot by a cop it has
to be racism even though the cop was
either black or the cop was latino
um who shot the guy uh it has to be
racist for some point and then they
always point out well cops did this and
cops did that all the time
and having someone like maxine waters
coming to the community doesn't make it
easy
having organizations like black lives
matter coming into the community doesn't
make it any easy
because you know if we have such an
issue with police
then what we need to be working on is
police reform we need to get social
training within our police
departments we need to get better
oversight committees within our police
department we need to increase the
budget so we can have better training
for
our police department and these aren't
things that people are bringing to the
table but these are things that i've
been able to work with
the mayor on and we were doing a really
good job so we've been standing in a gap
between the the police department and
the community making sure things stay
calm
and a lot of people from the you know
black lives matter organization don't
like it because they raise money off
hatred
and fear but at the end of the day when
it comes to taking responsibility
for the community this is something that
you know me and my team has done
has been doing yeah so i'm not a huge
fan
of eric garcetti our mayor here in l.a
can you want to try to sell me on him a
little bit or is this just one thing
you've been able to work with him on
no i'm not going to tell anybody on
mayor garcetti uh because he's he's
never sold anybody on me
but i think when you're in a leadership
position it is your obligation to work
with the people who are leaders in order
to affect better change and i don't have
a problem working
with anybody if it's going to create
some type of positive change
um do i like him personally maybe he's
uh he's a us navy sailor do i like his
policies you know sometimes i do
sometimes i don't but at the end of the
day
if we could take some some type of uh
some type of medium ground to build some
type of relationship to improve our
communities i'm with it
yeah so backing up for just a sec when
you hear people
talk about defunding the police and
everything else i've heard a lot of
people basically say this is just like a
media
construct like nobody really wants it
done is that what you're hearing from
nobody's going to defend the police
department i mean when you look at the
amount of gang violence and gun violence
domestic violence and drugs and
related incidents and and um you know
all these cases in our communities you
absolutely don't want to defund the
police the crazy part about it is the
same people who talk about defunding
police
are the same people who call the police
when something happens to them you know
so
it's never going to happen it's like a
red hair and it's the dumbest thing i've
ever heard in my entire life
yeah what do you make about just the the
general state of politics right now not
just
your district not just maxine waters but
like what's happening nationally
trump buying the the over and intense
focus on politics all day long
what do you think i think it's a mess i
think this is the complete reason why we
need term limits we have
uh politicians who refuse to work
together everybody want to be right
but they're trying to implement the same
things that they had in the 70s and 80s
it didn't work then it's not going to
work now
and we have a president who's struggling
trying to get things done for our
country and you know people just don't
want to work together so
we got to get these people out of office
on every single level at some
point these politicians should have been
aged out and created an avenue for
new uh younger politicians with fresh
ideas
yeah all right well listen i i wish we
had more time but uh we did this one on
the fly just because i saw the ad now i
wanted to help get the word out
i hope to see you in real life in la
your neighborhood or mine is fine with
me
for people that want to follow you and
and and help you before election time
where can they go
my website is joe collinsforcongress.com
you can find me on facebook and
instagram
at collins for congress four three and
you can find me at twitter or
joe collins 43rd and joe you got to hook
me up with the guy who did that video
because i i need some slick branding
like that man
all right i got you i got you all right
thanks a lot joe
all right talk to you later if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell